It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Are you awake?
No more 5 more minutes, I saw it!
You could've confused Moco-chan!
No more 5 more minutes, we're starting now!
But thank you!
Despite no more 5 minutes, thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 125th episode!
BAU BAU!
No more 5 minutes, but we'll take that 5 and we'll put it in the 125th.
Is that how it works?
That's how it works.
Okay, well, I guess.
BAU BAU!
Well, for those just waking up, and those maybe joining us for the first time!
You're always welcome!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Remember, Ruffians, if you remember the days of the week, FUWAMOCO Morning's on you better than Shiori.
What?
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you understand what I mean, right?
Moco-chan, you understand what I mean, right?
I-I guess.
Cause Shiori didn't know until we got to the 100th episode.
It's like, oh!
Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMOCO.
It's not the C. We did the Christmas FUWAMOCO already.
No, Ruffians don't understand, no.
What?
FWM.
Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMO.
Christmas.
Merry Christmas.
BAU BAU!
If you do that, you're better than Shiori, right?
I guess.
BAU BAU!
Let's bring this morning to sunrise.
With some bad news!
Bad news.
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Pero Sighting.
Let's take a look where he is again.
Rip off the band-aid.
Is he at another warehouse or something?
That's what you wanna do first thing in the morning.
Rip off the band-aid.
Let's see what he looks like.
De-den!
Birthday lunch!
With friends!
Yeah!
But he's sort of in a band-aid shape, but... Nevermind.
A nasty surprise on your birthday.
His eyes... They're so shiny!
Kinda shiny.
Yeah, the omelette kind of even looks... Fluffy!
Hot!
Salad looks pretty fresh.
Not fuzzy.
Yeah, not fuzzy.
Not a fuzzy salad.
You don't want a fuzzy salad!
Yeah, I bet you know it's all delicious.
But, uh...
Maybe, you know, just this time, you kind of have to help out by cleaning up this trash.
Yeah!
Sticking a knife right into the middle.
Clean it all up.
Yeah.
You know, cleaning up the trash on your birthday.
Is that okay, Moco-chan?
It's a nice thing to do, I guess.
Right.
It's my birthday, but I'll take out the trash.
Wow.
Yeah, very nice thing.
Yeah, thank you!
Thank you for making the world a better place by cleaning up this trash, getting rid of the nastiness.
Yeah, cleaning up the nastiness, huh?
Yeah, right?
Very good.
That's so good though.
No, it's just horrible trash.
Nasty.
But we'll eat it.
It's probably delicious.
BAU BAU!
I hope you had a good birthday despite it all!
Happy birthday!
BAU BAU!
Well, chat's just said... Ruffians! Something really big just happened!
In hololive English history!
That big!
Do you know what it is, Ruffians?
hololive English history we're talking!
Breaking Dimensions, yes, but... But!
Well... Our shark senpai from hololive English -Myth-, Gura-senpai!
Gura-senpai just revealed her 2.0!
Did you see?
Look!
Look at it here!
Look how cute Gura-senpai is!
It's absolutely amazing!
Amazing!
Right?
Snazzy!
Yeah!
You know, it's like Gura-senpai after a really really nice spa treatment.
It's a spa treatment!
Yeah!
Spa treatment for a sock!
Sharks need a spa day.
Why not?
Some bubbles.
Extra bubbles.
Maybe like a sand bath.
I like sand paper.
Sharks take sand baths.
That's kind of regular for them though.
Mud bath.
Mud bath sounds so regular maybe.
Baby.
I don't know.
But you know now Gura-senpai she moves so fluidly.
Looks so cute.
Especially with that... The cat shark move.
Yeah!
Can you believe it?
Kuro-senpai got even cuter!
I didn't think it was possible, Ruffians!
Mine's super fluid now!
Yeah.
Look at that face!
Yeah, just like that!
But my teeth are still there!
Yeah!
Didn't take away her teeth.
No.
I know.
She's a shark, you know.
She needs her teeth, you know?
We're just so happy that Gura-senpai got a bit of a makeover, you know?
You know, she just must be so elated too!
Congratulations, Gura-senpai!
Yeah, no one can take the fangs.
No, no, no, no.
No bottom teeth though.
You have to take all the bottom teeth and still really, really do some damage, huh?
Cute is the priority, right?
Extreme violence later.
That's our motto.
I really hope that I can get to see Gura-senpai's cute face lots and lots!
BAU BAU!
Baudotiti?
No!
Can't have too much of a good thing, right?
Do we need... Moco-chan!
Oh, are you sad?
Would you like me more if I had teeth?
Moco-chan, we're making this about you again!
How?
Look, I can eat so well.
We have fangs, Ruffians!
Look at my fangs!
Watch out!
Yeah.
They might just not be as sharp as a shark.
But that's because we're demon dogs!
It's sharp on my claws!
Yeah.
Watch out for the claws.
But I will validate the tickets, okay?
Yeah, we can do that.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
There's also some really big news too!
Incredible news!
Yeah!
You know, Advent, we just had our first anniversary!
Which means...
ReGLOSS!
ReGLOSS is now celebrating their first anniversary too!
BAU BAU!
And of course the first anniversary comes with a bunch of cool things going on!
Well, they just released their newest song, Feeling Gradation!
And it has a fully animated MV!
It's so amazing!
They're dancing!
Yeah, dancing, singing!
All, you know, just like beautiful idols in animated glory!
Yeah!
You better go check it out!
Yeah, look!
Look at them all there!
Ririka, Tami.
Oh, Moco-chan.
Excuse me.
I've been thinking huh?
That is looking kind of fluffy there.
Hi!
Then we got some great outfits!
But not just a brand new song with an amazing MV.
Not just that!
But!
We got!
They'll be having their 3 day debut!
It's gonna be on September 28th GST!
Their first 3D online concert!
Are you ready?
Reach the top.
Yeah, reach the top.
So close and too short, Kai.
What?
Moco-chan!
They can't reach the top because they're too short!
We're 155 centimeters.
I'm not seeing anything.
I think we have to reach the top too.
But we just can't wait, you know.
3D debut means we get to see their singing, their dancing!
I wonder what it'll be like, maybe.
Well, we don't have to wait too long.
Just in a few weeks, on the 28th, JST, we'll be able to see them on 3D!
And, not just that.
Not just that!
There's been so many announcements!
But there's more!
Wow, Wigwoss will also be releasing an album filled with 8 songs!
8 full songs!
Full songs!
Oh my gosh!
Makes sense, you know Wigwoss being the idol group that they all write together.
Right!
No way!
Writing 8 songs!
A whole full album!
Yeah!
Let's go!
We can't wait to hear what it sounds like!
Right!
Oh, what kind of ReGLOSS are they gonna show us with their new music?
Glossier?
I don't... If they become glossier, they might just... Gloss into the universe.
We need that to stay here.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, have you noticed something going on, you know, with FUWAMOCO here?
You know, have you maybe smelled a certain scent from FUWAMOCO?
What?
Extreme violence!
Yeah!
The scent of extreme violence we have!
Cause right now we have a special collab together with World of Tanks Blitz!
Oh!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But you know, FUWAMOCO will help you in the best areas possible.
You know, things like, you know, getting our special collectible FUWAMOCO donut.
You know, a donut is very important to a tank.
It is!
It's what tanks run on.
You may think, oh they run on whatever tanks run on.
But they run on donuts.
Donuts are a very important part.
There's other things too, you know.
Special FUWAMOCO avatars.
Also a snazzy FUWAMOCO skin that you can use just for your tag too.
I'm a fuzz.
So yeah, please go check it out, okay?
We're together with our senpai and our biboo too.
If you ever want to miss it, it will end.
February 27th is on right now, so check it out!
Go check it out!
You can finally get the FUWAMOCO Iida tank of your dreams too!
You've all been waiting for it, right?
Right.
You want... That's always what you dreamed about.
Forget the Iida car!
Forget, you know, new original song, FUWAMOCO tank.
FUWAMOCO, please go check out one of those tanks, please!
Thanks, you're welcome!
You're welcome!
You don't have to thank me so much.
You're welcome, okay?
FUWAMOCO-chan!
You get my joke?
I finally do.
You're welcome!
BAU BAU!
Oh, I like the title, World of Thanks Blitz.
World of Thanks?
Yeah, it's a positive world, you know.
So much thanks.
Wow.
No, not World of Thanks.
World of Thanks!
World of Time Splits.
BAU BAU!
What was that?
I was just worried that maybe we continued this corner even before we got to it.
That's what I was thinking too.
Ruffians!
There's been a...
Misunderstanding.
Hopefully nothing new other than... Yeah.
It's been a while, but it's been a misunderstanding, Ruffians.
Yuto!
First of all!
We had anorecho, right?
Yeah!
Anomatic recollection.
Do you remember what that was?
It was so long ago.
I hope your memories didn't get wiped.
That would be really horrible.
We don't want that.
Yeah.
But it was a big event that all of hololive English was a part of!
We went into a very special world, the kingdom of Lobesto, in a place that's kind of looking familiar to Minecraft, but different!
And we solved some mysteries.
Maybe got some memories back, maybe didn't.
Maybe there was some sad things.
But!
Oh!
The most important thing that I feel like
Many people forgot.
Oh, is that not their memories?
No.
Oh.
And a record is roleplay.
Ah!
What does that mean, Moco-chan?
That means that the Fuwawa and the Mococo that you see there are different.
Different?
Different, like, different, different.
Ah!
It's not, it's not.
Mococo!
You're not Mococo, you're Mococo.
You put it like that?
Yes.
You remember that now?
Well, it's FWC.
The FW is a little different, right?
You know, the FW is FWC.
Wow.
She really loves her chickens.
Ah!
Bread smell!
But the Fuwawa never go love the chickens.
It doesn't mean that the Fuwawa here right now doesn't like chickens too, huh?
They're handy.
Fluffy.
Sometimes.
Ruffians, you should be looking at this, right?
Did you notice the difference?
The cape!
Not the cape.
You thought it was just the cape, huh?
But you were wrong!
Not the cape.
Oh!
I see- Oh!
Two Ruffians- Three Ruffians!
Yes!
No headband!
Yeah!
See the Mocoi- Mococo!
The Mococo with no headband was thought to have mercilessly killed- Mercilessly killed Fuwawa's beloved chickens.
Actually, that Mococo is innocent!
No, no, no.
What happened?
She was trying to close the gate door into the chicken pen.
So that all the chickens stay inside the pen.
Because Fuwawa's friend is trying to be helpful.
But she mis-pressed the button and used revelation and killed them all.
That was pretty horrifying to watch, huh?
If you go back and listen, you can hear the horror in her voice, okay?
I'm innocent.
Likely story.
Likely story, Hans.
No!
It's a misunderstanding!
You understand now.
Not join!
You have to go take a look at the evidence of maybe Ruffians.
Okay.
And then you can be true.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
We are telling them!
It is a misunderstanding!
This is the truth.
That's how a misunderstanding goes.
Now you say, I understand.
Has been a long time, but that's... Understandable.
Got it?
I didn't say understandable.
I understand.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes.
Got it?
I understand.
BAU BAU!
Misunderstanding.
Misunderstanding?
Clear.
World of Tanks Blitz.
BAU BAU!
Well, it's Wednesday.
It's Wednesday.
Are you ready for Wednesday, Ruffians?
Wednesday.
Has it been a little rough so far this week?
Maybe it's been a bit.
Well, Wednesday's gonna be rough too.
Maybe Moco-chan, you can make it not so rough on a Wednesday.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I think you should know what day it is, huh?
Wednesday!
Because this year is a Mococo Pup Talk!
So you're gonna shoot straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians, it's Wednesday!
And you know what?
I feel like today...
This year is going to be a different kind of Pup Talk.
Today, I want to bless you with good feelings!
It's not like every week I don't want to bless you with good feelings, but today especially!
I want to bless you with good feelings!
Okay.
So, here I go!
Wake up refreshed!
Lots of energy!
Voice is happy!
A on the test!
This is so comfortable!
Super FUWAMOCO!
That was a bit different.
Yeah, it was Pup Talk mix.
Pup Talk mix?
Fire!
Pup Talk.
Boss is happy!
It's a good time!
Good luck everyone!
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at our regular corners now.
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
We have De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Sienna!
Sienna!
She has cute eyes.
Big puppy dog eyes.
Oh, it's a voice.
Right!
Look at those eyebrows, too!
Yeah, so curious!
Yeah, those are so fleek!
Right!
Sienna's a rescue and super duper cute!
And then she rescued you, right?
Right!
She rescued you!
But look, she's just a big puppy!
A big puppy with a big barker and an even bigger heart!
And guess what, Moco-chan?
Sienna loves to give overbearing cuddles too.
Does she?
Yeah.
Oh.
Interesting.
Very cute.
Very cute!
FUWAMOCO-chan, how do you think Sienna BAU BAUs?
I think like, when she wants to cuddle.
BAU BAU!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Wow, I don't need to say this really.
We can all tell already.
But Sienna's just so sweet.
And you can see in those eyes just how happy she is to be a part of your family.
A part of your heart!
I hope that you know she lays on your lap even more.
And that maybe she'll share some of those cuddles with us too.
Yeah, okay!
Nobody doesn't like cuddles.
Right cuddles, please.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Today I Went On A Walk!
We have De-den!
I like this kind of walk!
Miracle boy!
Your calico buddy blessed you with presents!
You have been blessed!
Oh my gosh!
Treat, huh?
In many ways.
A treat for you, maybe.
You have a treat there for the calico boy, too.
Well, FUWAMOCO, we recommend this cat treat.
Churu.
I've heard that all cats can't resist the churu.
Some less than others.
Young.
Young, huh?
Bring Calico Buddy a churu and I'm sure... She'll be happy.
He'll be happy.
Buddy will be happy.
Yeah.
Hi!
I saw some Calico facts there!
Calico facts?
Yeah, that Calico cats are 99% girls.
I don't care!
Cats are cute and that's all that matters!
Well, you know if you bring some churu, maybe a calico bunny will be there lots in the future.
And then you can have lots of fun with your calico-flavored walks.
BAU BAU!
So cute.
I want to go on walks like that too.
Teach me how to find walks like that.
Well, on our Question of the Day, we have de-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Summer is almost over.
Do Fuwawa and Mococo have anything they would like to do or eat in the fall?
It's also the season of sweet potatoes, so there will be many delicious sweets and other delicacies.
First a secret, Ruffians!
Last FUWAMOCO Morning, I did partake in a fall delicacy shortly beforehand, and I made a mistake.
You know we have the delicious Sama.
The Sama fish is good in the fall time.
And so all FUWAMOCO Morning, I had a bone stuck in my throat.
Yes.
But!
We really like sweet potatoes too!
But Fuwawa, the whole time before hajimaru said, I don't know what I'm gonna do, what I'm gonna have.
I couldn't get most of them because I have a bullet in my throat.
I have to be like, Ruffians, I'm sorry right now!
The summer, it's stuck!
I'm sorry!
But that's okay!
You have to be careful, okay?
But sweet potatoes, sweet potatoes!
I wanna find the Yankee Moji-san!
And then we wanna buy it all!
Yaki-mo.
I want to buy all the best potatoes in the Yaki-mo ojisan.
You just hear the song in the distance and then... I'm looking forward to it.
The fall time is wonderful too!
It was a wonderful summer, but I'm sure there's going to be a wonderful fall waiting for us too!
Let's make it fun again!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
I don't hear the day, the Question of the Day!
Why?
For sharing your walks with us, your Pero Sightings!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Let's continue to be a big and fortified FUWAMOCO Morning by using the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Wow, next we have another stream coming right on up right!
We have De-den!
We're gonna be playing Elite Exorcist Miko!
The newest game from hololive AP!
It looks super fun.
I'm really excited.
It looks very very addicting but we're gonna make it.
Are we?
I know my Senchou-senpai was talking of great things about this game, so I'm very excited to try it out all together with you, my friends!
Let's have a bunch of fun, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a peek at our schedule!
FUWAMOCO's schedule!
Oh, but... Unfortunately, earlier we couldn't quite play Donkey Kong Country 2, but... I'm sorry.
Moco-chan, you're feeling much better from your mic right now.
Yeah, I still...
It's funny!
It notches my head that hurts after everything hurts.
But we're getting better, okay?
We'll say hello to Donkey Kong Country 2 next week!
And then on Friday, we have FUWAMOCO Morning followed by a nice cozy chat while we do some super chat reading.
And then on Saturday, it's time for a rock n' roar party!
Rock n' roar time!
We hope you're ready, Ruffians.
And then on Sunday, it's been a while since our last horror game.
Maybe that was a good thing.
But we're gonna be going to a bathhouse.
One said two.
A restored bathhouse.
And hopefully we won't see anything scary.
Yeah.
Hopefully.
And that's our schedule for this week, Ruffians!
Oh!
And for Ruffians who are joining us this morning through the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO Rune!
It's BAU BAU WOW!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU WOW!
BAU BAU WOW.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Gabriel D!
BAU BAU!
Wiggles!
Deephose!
BAU BAU!
Tile7!
Wiggle the Shimp!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!